there are plenty of twists and
spider-man far from home and with
everything going on there were bound to
be a few questions that got tangled up
in the web of illusion from cliffhangers
to dangling plot threads to reveals with
massive implications for the future of
the MCU here are the biggest unanswered
questions in spider-man far from home
spoilers ahead the after credits scene
and spider-man far from home dropped
several bombs in quick succession and
introduces multiple questions about the
future of the MCU the scene sees Nick
Fury and Maria Hill driving when
surprised they turn into Skrulls well
technically the Skrulls who were
masquerading as fury in hill revealed
their true forms it turns out that for
the entire movie the scroll Sauron and
Talos were covering for the former
shield agents Talos then calls someone
to report on everything that just went
down in Europe and we see that he's
talking to none other than Nick Fury
himself who's on some sort of spaceship
or high-tech base manned by Skrulls but
where is he well while the film doesn't
give any concrete answers there's one
possibility that would open up a whole
new world now that far from home has
officially closed the door on MCU phase
3 we're on the cusp of a future where
the MCU gets a lot bigger and more
cosmic a bigger universe means bigger
threats and what's poor little planet
Earth to do in the face of intergalactic
alien invaders easy build a big Space
Station to protect the world from
extraterrestrial threats
fortunately someone's already done that
sword or the sentient world observation
and response department which debuted an
astonishing x-men in 2004 and went on to
appear in issues of Captain Marvel and
Secret Invasion to name a few comic
titles
it's basically shield in space and it
operated as a subdivision of shield is
that where Nick Fury was there's nothing
in the film to confirm it but if the
post-credits scene a far from home did
in fact introduce sword it's kind of a
big deal see since it debuted in an
x-men comic the film rights to the
agency had long been mired in the whole
Fox Marvel legal rights struggle
now the Disney's acquisition of Fox has
gone through however that years long
question of who owns what is a moot
point and the introduction of sword may
just mark one of the first steps
bringing parts of these different
universes together spider-man far from
homes plot is all about how appearances
can be deceiving its central villain
Mysterio uses complex Holograms to trick
the world into thinking monsters are
coming out of the ground and he puts
that tech to good use in his battles
with Spidey plunging our hero into a
world where nothing is what it seems
he's full of tricks our magic trick
illusion silent slave
paranoia and illusion or all pieces of
the puzzle here which makes the end
credits reveal that Maria Hill and Nick
Fury were Skrulls the whole time so
perfect but that also raises another
question with even bigger ramifications
fury has known about and potentially
been working with the Skrulls since the
90s the decade where Captain Marvel is
set despite Carole promising to find
them a new home some Skrulls apparently
hung around on earth and fury clearly
has no more qualms about letting them
impersonate important people does this
mean we should expect other characters
to turn out to be secret scrolls
hopefully not but now that the cats out
of the bag
anything is possible like Tom Holland
himself Peter Parker is terrible at
keeping secrets
far from home marks the second solo
Spidey movie in the MCU and it also
marks the second solo Spidey movie in
the MCU were the main bad guy knows
Peter's real identity kill you and
everybody you know in the mid credit
scene Mysterio reveals spider-man's
identity to the world which is one of
Peters biggest fears he just watched
Quentin Beck target his closest friends
with murder drones so he has first-hand
knowledge of the dangers of having your
secret identity exposed
now that the whole world knows who he is
his life is basically open season for
any bad guy who may want a piece of the
spider pie we know from homecoming that
scorpions itching to get back at
spider-man who else might join the bug
hunt all his friends and loved ones are
in danger and even his home is no longer
safe
clearly the reveal was intended as a
cliffhanger for a third spider-man film
and it's the kind of question that could
lead in any direction for a movie about
spider-man far from home sure spends a
lot of time focusing on Iron Man
specifically on the vacancy Tony Stark
left behind there's a hole in the
Avengers roster a hole in Peters heart
and a hole in the world where the
armored Avenger used to stand Peter
himself grapples with the question of
whether he is or at least is supposed to
be the next Iron Man you go min next
Iron Man now well no I don't have time
I'm too busy doing your jobs I'm kidding
I'm kidding he even gets into the spirit
of Tony when he gets to work building
his new suit while listening to his
favorite Led Zeppelin song ac/dc is back
in black but ultimately there is no
answer to be found in spider-man far
from home the film builds the question
to a crescendo then leaves it hanging
there presumably for a future MCU
installment darn you and your endless
sequels marble check out one of our
newest videos right here Plus even more
looper videos about your favorite
superhero films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]